Welcome to Level 4
multiplication.
Let's do some problems.
Let's see, we had 235 times--
I'm going to use two different
colors here, so bear
with me a second.
Let's say times 47.
So you start a Level 4 problem
just like you would normally
do a Level 3 problem.
We'll take that 7, and
we'll multiply it by 235.
So 7 times 5 is 35.
7 times 3 is 21, plus the
3 we just carried is 24.
7 times 2 is 14, plus
the 2 we just carried.
This is 16.
So we're done with the 7.
Now we have to
deal with this 4.
Well, since that 4 is in the
tens place, we add a 0 here.
You could almost view it as
we're multiplying 235, not by
4, but we're multiplying it
by 40, and that's why
we put that 0 there.
But once you put the 0 there,
you can treat it just like a 4.
So you say 4 times
5, well, that's 20.
Let's ignore what we
had from before.
4 times 3 is 12, plus the 2 we
just carried, which is 14.
4 times 2 is 8, plus the 1 we
just carried, so that's 9.
And now we just add
up everything.
5 plus 0 is 5, 4 plus 0 is 4, 6
plus 4 is 10, carry the 1, and
1 plus 9, well, that's 11.
So the answer's 11,045.
Let's do another problem.
Let's say I had 873 times-- and
I'm making these numbers up on
the fly, so bear with me-- 873
times-- some high numbers--
90-- and I'm doing them in
different colors, just so you
hopefully get a better
understanding of what
I'm trying to explain.
Let's say 97.
No, I just used a 7.
Let's make it 98.
So just like we did before, we
go to the ones place first, and
that's where that 8 is, and
we multiply that 8 times 873.
So 8 times 3 is
24, carry the 2.
8 times 7 is 56, plus
2 is 58, carry the 5.
8 times 8 is 64, plus
the 5 we just carried.
That's 69.
We're done with the 8.
Now we have to multiply the
9, or we could just do it as
we're multiplying 873 by 90.
But multiplying something by 90
is just the same thing as
multiplying something by 9 and
then adding a 0 at the end, so
that's why I put a 0 here.
Let's say 9 times 3-- well,
first, just to clean up
things, let's get rid of
what we had from before.
We say 9 times 3 is
27, carry the 2.
9 times 7 is 63, plus the 2
that we just carried is 65.
Carry the 6.
8 times 8 is 72, plus
the 6 we just carried.
That's 78.
And now we just add again.
4, 8 plus 7 is 15, 1 plus 9
plus 5 is 15, 1 plus 6 plus
8 is also 15, and 1
plus 7, that's 8.
So the answer, hopefully-- I
don't have a calculator in
front of me-- is 85,554,
assuming I didn't make
any careless mistakes.
Let's do one more problem.
I think it'll hit
the point home.
The next problem I'm going to
do, you can almost do it as a
Level 5 problem because I'm
actually going to multiply two
three-digit numbers, but it's
really the same thing, and
hopefully, you'll
see the pattern.
So let's say I had 234 times--
and I'm going to use three
colors now-- let's say 643.
So first we do the 3, which
is in the ones place, and
we multiply that times 234.
Well, 3 times 4 is
12, carry the 1.
3 times 3 is 9, add the 1.
That's 10, carry the 1.
3 times 2 is 6, plus 1.
Well, that's 7.
And then we've done the--
I think I've made a
mistake someplace.
Let me see.
3 times 4 is 12.
Oh, no, I think that's correct.
I was confusing myself.
OK, now we're ready to do the
4, or the 40, and since it's a
40 because it's in the tens
place, we put a 0 right here.
We say 4 times 4-- well, let's
clean up this stuff at the top.
I always forget to do that.
4 times 4, well, that's
16, carry the 1.
4 times 3, well, that's 12,
plus 1, well, that's 13.
4 times 2 is 8, plus
the 1, well, that's 9.
And now we're done with the
4, or the 40, depending on
how you want to view it.
Now we're ready for
the 6, or the 600.
Since it's a 600, we put
two zeroes here, and we
just treat it like a 6.
Let's clean up what
we did before.
So 6 times 4 is
24, carry the 2.
6 times 3 is 18, plus
2 is 20, carry the 2.
6 times 2 is 12, plus 2 is 14.
And now we add it all up.
2, 6, 7 plus 3 is 10.
14, carry the 1.
1 plus 9 is 10, carry the 1.
That's 5.
That's 1.
I hope you can see.
I hope it's not falling off
the screen, the answer
I get is a 150,462.
I think you're ready
now to try Level 4
multiplication problems.